new images confirm a massive iceberg
about the size of Delaware broke off
this ice shelf in Antarctica we first
told you about this dramatic split
yesterday a NASA satellite captured this
picture of the one trillion ton iceberg
it broke off the Larsen sea ice shelf
and is one of the biggest icebergs ever
recorded the ice shelf is in the
southernmost part of the world on the
western side of Antarctica this crack in
the Larsen sea ice shelf had grown to
more than 120 miles before it broke off
this week producing one of the largest
icebergs ever recorded its size is
staggering more than 2,200 square miles
twice the volume of Lake Erie this
collapse on the western peninsula of
Antarctica follows the collapse of two
other ice shelves Larsen a and Larsen B
which broke off were on the turn of the
century it was sort of unprecedented
because it hadn't happened in 10,000
years look all that pretty unprecedented
Ken Taylor is one of America's foremost
ice scientists we interviewed him when
we visited in arctica in February he
says it's not the floating icebergs that
are concerning but the fact that these
ice shelves serve as a doorstop to keep
glacial ice on land from melting quickly
and drifting out to sea when that ice
can flow into the sea and melt that does
have caused a rising sea level there are
several spots around here around
Antarctica that are believed to be in
this irreversible situation where the
ice on the ground is going to flow into
the sea and there's nothing we can do to
stop it at this point
Taylor believes that could drive sea
levels up even more than the three feet
already predicted for this century
scientists say the landscape of the an
Arctic Peninsula has changed
fundamentally now researchers will be
studying how this break will affect the
rest of the ice shelf the importance of
what's happening here is that it gives a
proxy as to what may happen to the rest
of a tareka as the rest of Antartica
keeps warming up sort of a wake-up call
for what he's rooming and had
interesting is they talk about this
break off causing map makers to know
early rewrites Maps yes and then we'll
be talking about the rising ocean levels
and what that means somebody to explain
to our kids a lot to explore here yeah